this morning we want to tell you about a
remarkable non-profit group with a
mission
to help lift up single mothers and break
down negative stereotypes
the woman behind this group is using her
own experience to help empower hundreds
of single black mothers
meg oliver has her story put your
seatbelt on son
once a month crystal edwards a
philadelphia elementary school principal
all right we are here rents a u-haul
truck open
up the side door and i'll get to that
and pulls up to this walmart
let's do it her mission to give back to
single moms
oh they love the pampers through a
partnership the store
donates packed pallets of items from
heaters and microwaves to barbie dream
houses
listen to a barbie dream house i never
had one my mother couldn't afford that
it all started when edwards found
herself a single mom at 27 years old
right after you became a single mom
after your divorce someone made a
comment to you what did they say
i was in the store and someone said
here's another one these children with
no fathers and i'm thinking to myself
wow you don't even know my story do you
believe there's a perception
that black women are the face of single
moms i absolutely
do biases and prejudices that did not
reflect
the hard work the lack of access
the overwhelming sense of i'm doing this
work by myself
the newly remarried mom of four set out
to change the perception
in 2015 her non-profit empowering single
moms
inc was born and we're really focusing
on
getting women off of any type of
government
assistance we do an assessment where are
you today and where are you trying to
get to and
we partner and network to make sure
that those women are able to reach those
goals
everybody has their number okay their
distributions take place across
pennsylvania delaware in new jersey
we're going to be here until everything
is going they advertise on social media
in church bulletins and through word of
mouth
on this day dozens lined up in the cold
outside her elementary school in north
philadelphia
she keeps a database of names and if
they're willing to work
offers a networking program with
resources helping
single moms achieve education housing
assistance
and employment when you first met
christo what did you need
i don't think meg the question of what
did i need but just more
what didn't i need 33 year old chanel
odoms needed a job with
hours that matched her daughter's school
day you just met her randomly through a
distribution site
i just love it yes with chanel's
professional background in mental health
crystal was able to get her a job as a
classroom assistant at her school
has she helped you get off public
assistance yes now
i'm completely off of that crystal has
helped more than 400 women
her dream is to raise enough money for a
van for pickups
and a small building to offer workshops
and face-to-face counseling
this is life-changing work this is
transformational work this
is the servant work i watch the feet of
the community and i tell people
that all the time this is not glitz and
glamour this is building people
up come on babe building people up to be
their best
she has the best energy now at this one
event more than 100 single moms received
the much needed household items even
some holiday gifts crystal is in the
process of following up with each of
them to see how she can help them in
other aspects
of their lives tony oh meg thank you
very much hey
thank you meg for the introduction love
everything about christopher's including
her glasses
yes yes i like what meg said about her
energy just the fact that somebody would
say something so disparaging about you
and know nothing about you
just sort of sent her on another path i
agree completely i mean what i will say
about fathers though you know
crystal's right we don't know her story
we don't know any of the stories of
women in those lines but i do know that
there's a father somewhere behind that
child and if they're not
helping out like they should maybe they
should see that piece and and see if
they can do more
yeah that's a reminder as well crystal
edwards is a formidable woman yes
i love i can see how she takes charge i
love it